seit der gründung von wie schmeckt's im
jahre 1903 einhalb jahren fragte mich
schon kannst du mal die blue dogs m und
kehrt machen bitte mach mal die blue
dogs oder aus dem und kehrt bitte mal
die blue dogs oder aus hellem und kehrt
staffel 1 episode der gips oder außerdem
habe ich eure kommentare ignoriert denn
um ehrlich zu sein habe ich sam und
kehrt nie geschaut aber das bedeutet
nicht dass ich kein fan von supersüßen
spahni bund work i bis iv
denn auch ich bin mit sowie hannover
nahm verbeeks rangers und co
aufgewachsen also let's take a look at
some and carry als allererstes ariane
kranz spielt mit und hat rote haare
watts und was macht die alte aus alkali
in dieser serie
zweitens ich habe gerade aus recherche
angefangen verfolgt anzuschauen und ich
kann einfach nicht aufhören daher kommen
wir zu drittens und mit drittens meine
ich was ich aus dem wikipedia kopiere
die beiden schülerinnen sam paket und
kehrt wellen zahlen die sich eine
wohnung teilen sich zusammen um ein baby
sitting unternehmen zu gründen um damit
ihre aufregenden abenteuer zu
finanzieren also kurz gesagt to go girls
mit weniger sex humor und dafür einer
viel zu krass eingerichteten wohnung das
führt bei mir zu ein paar fragen wieso
müssen sie überhaupt arbeiten wenn die
wohnung schon so krasse das schreibt
auch nach reiche eltern und wieso wohnen
sie nicht bei diesen reichen eltern wenn
sie noch zur schule gehen und die
wichtigste frage wieso haben sie ariana
grande rote haare gemacht aber kommen
wir zu der blue dogs oder die auf
netflix bei staffel 1 spätfolgen 9
vorkommt was auch immer 1b sein soll es
geht darum dass die beliebte blue dogs
oder von der regierung verboten wird da
sie anscheinend zu viel zucker hat und
die leute zu viel davon trinken deshalb
entscheidet sich sam dazu sie selbst
dazu stellen nachdem cat sie probiert
und die kopie als schlecht empfindet
macht sie klar wonach blue dogs oder
überhaupt schmecken muss und wie schafft
es eine perfekte kopie zu kreieren und
dann babysitten sie natürlich wieder und
alles endet im chaos wie bei einer
typischen disney channel serie und bevor
ihr noch länger darauf warten müsst
stellen wir uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt die
tu doch so dass sam und kate das ist
diesmal nicht so eine schwierige frage
denn die bekommen von cat ganz genau
gesagt wie das geschmacksprofil die
valimo ist unser erster hinweis es ist
eine 60 zu 40 mischung aus vanille und
zitrus meine frage ist nun wie weiß ich
denn was eine 60 zu 40 mir schon daraus
ist mittlerweile glaube ich ich hätte
vielleicht lieber einfach künstliche
aromen geben sollen aber irgendwie fühlt
sich das dann auch nicht so richtig
haben uns nicht den kopf darüber zu
zerbrechen machen wir einfach eine
vanilleschote und eine zitrone rein und
hoffen einfach dass das eine gute pace
ist für die blue dog lima hat kommt als
nächstes wacholder kirchen ecke und eine
spur muskat okay frage jetzt
wahrscheinlich warum habe ich gehabt
seine kirche genommen
ganz einfach hätte ich kirchen genommen
wer das rot geworden egal welche kirche
nicht genommen hätte aus dem glas
frische es wäre ein roter saft geworden
also brauche ich kirsch aroma damit es
farbneutral bleiben dann wollte ich erst
mal von amazon so fleisch drops
bestellen kirsch aroma künstlich ist und
wo es mehr künstliches kirsch aroma drin
1 in karten sonne ja ohne künstliche
süßstoffe und farbstoff ohne
konservierungsstoffe künstliche aromen
oder sauerkirsch sagt zitronensaft
limetten sagt natürliches aroma
ich habe auch schon zitrone aber wir
machen auf jeden fall mehr zitrone also
ich glaube dass capri sonne kirche
farbneutral ist ganz vom gleichen rosat
ist ich mache gerade nun geschmacks
studien dass mit vollmacht ihr schon
acht wirklich aber auch schon nach
zitrone
danach sehen wir dass sie auf jeden fall
braunen zucker verwendet
ich dich und nun kommen wir zu unserem
nächsten hinweis censored nämlich bei
minute 14
das traum saft mehr zucker als limo hat
und dann dachte ich so traubensaft
zuckergehalt 14 gramm auf 100 milliliter
oder 100 gramm und limo hat ungefähr
zehn gramm oder elf gramm was hat ein
cola cola ist die bekannteste limo und
cola ist erlaubt und die blutung wurde
verboten wegen der zuckergehalt kohl hat
neun kann und traum sagt hat wird das
heißt unsere limo hat zwischen 9 und 14
gramm zucker bank sie sich befinden wenn
cola in der serie erlaubt ist denke ich
jetzt mal die blut verboten wurde weil
sie zu zuckerhaltig ist und sagt das
aber traumhaft mehr zucker hat als die
blue dog das bedeutet dass die blue dog
zwischen 10 und 13 gramm zucker haben
muss pro 100 gramm
immer wenn man sich anstrengt
aber das bedeutet wenn wir ein liter
wasser nehmen dann müssen wir 100 gramm
zucker machen und dann wenn der sirup
fertig ist müssen wir koppeln wieviel
sirup ist noch übrig und wie viel wasser
eis verdampft damit wir am ende wenn wir
sprudel drauf machen ungefähr diesen
wert erreichen all das schöne
wundert mich gar nicht warum ich so
lange dieses rezept nicht ausprobieren
hat ja guter lasst uns jetzt mal einen
sirup erstellen aus dem wir am ende
locker machen können wir starten mit
einer mischung aus rohrzucker und weißem
zucker fett macht zwar sehr braunen
zucker rein ich sehe aber gerade dass es
dadurch so eine gelbliche farbe annimmt
und unser sirup sei am ende blau sein
das tut mir leid
und jetzt nochmal 100 gramm weißer
zucker oder auch kaum wieder einen liter
wasser das sind nur 600 und diese
leckere zuckerwasser mir schon kochen
wir jetzt auf so dass von einer
christlich zeigt euch das mal so hier
setzt der topf ich habe keine gute
erfahrung mit zucker heiß machen ich
habe mich mal übels verbrannt wird das
kochbuch gemacht haben wo ist die narbe
ist immer noch die narbe es war ein
dilemma aber ich hab's aus als nichts
brauchen wir den saft und die schale von
visa bio zitrone dafür waschen wir die
zitrone kreis ab von dann zählen wir
diese bio zitrone aus wie eine zitrone
und meine lieblingsfarbe müssen so viel
zitronenaroma wie möglich nehmen denn
wenn ich diese vanilleschote da rein
machen müsste vielleicht nur eine heile
über eine rein machen das wird ein
richtiges vanille aroma wie gut es
gerade hier den richtern jetzt haben wir
einen mexiko
[Musik]
die zitrone halbieren wir suchen den
saft kino irgendwo warst du die
zitronenpresse gebracht da wir jetzt die
zitronenpresse haben drücken wir nur
noch den zitronensaft aus und geben ihn
in unseren top dann brauchen wir noch
unser vanilleschote 60 zu 40 und
gleichzeitig doch die ganze macht wird
so krass nachgehen zu können aber nur
die hälfte wurde man in der schule
ich gebe die vanilleschote den topf war
und damit das aroma wirklich schön wird
nach zitronen nelken also nelken riechen
so krass da würde ich jetzt nur eine
erstmal muskat benutzen wir nur ganz
wenig und dann natürlich noch die guten
wacholderbeeren die vom bios übrig
geblieben sind von dem auch ein krasses
aroma drei stück 3 war heute eine kleine
prise muskat und jetzt kommt noch kirche
weil in unserer capri sonne ja schon
zucker drin ist können wir die einfach
hinzufügen ohne dass wir noch hinzufügen
müssen das ja auch ein bisschen zitrone
drin
ein bisschen rosa halt dein maul man
schmeckt wie vanille man schmeckt die
zitrone man schmecken hauch kirche und
irgendwas neviges war holder muskat
es gab noch einen enkel kann ein
bisschen muskat auf jeden fall nicht
noch eine vanille eine halbe vanille
reichsstraße wird jetzt in san siro und
den stellen wird auch volle pulle und
ich lasse es jetzt so eine stunde kochen
eine stunde speckte der sirup ist
gekocht wir haben jetzt goldenen wie
ruppig weil ich habe hier etwas anders
machen müssen und da sind viele
stückchen drin wir brauchen einen tee
filter unseren sirup zu filtern
[Musik]
so fühlten wird unseren sirup da als das
gold eine dreckige küche und das gold
könnte sein dass ich vielleicht das zu
heiß gemacht habe und es deswegen
karamellisiert ist kann sein dass wir
jetzt eine green dort limo haben werden
100 milliliter sirup mit einem liter
wasser aufgießen und dann haben wir zehn
gramm zucker pro 100 milliliter und
gewerbe und das ist mehr als cola und
weniger als traumhaft dagegen können wir
nichts
und damit das so richtig schön aussehen
wie das in dieser klasse ein test und
hier nochmal beweis essent 100 ist
einfach unglaublich sieht einfach aus
wie selbst gemacht obwohl ich bin so
gespannt was timo sagt weil ich bin
immer ein bisschen voreingenommen für
blut-doping brauchen wir natürlich blaue
lebensmittelfarbe
jetzt fühlen wir unsere blut auf limo in
die flasche und jetzt brauchen wir noch
sprudelwasser das war keine so dass
stream werbung das muss jetzt da ein
[Musik]
okay weil da geht's das ist der
vorsichtige schütte prozess ich habe es
geschafft ich habe eine flasche blue
dogs oder gemacht und nun stellen wir
uns der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt die blue dogs oder aus sam und
ich hab's geschafft ich hasse ich hab's
fischer ich habe ich möchte erstmal
meiner community danken
danke dass ihr das so oft vorgeschlagen
habe ich euch bin ich da wo ich heute
bin und darauf trinken wir es wertvoller
als schampus daraus leitet
[Musik]
nun mein gott ist das lecker das ist so
lecker also man schmeckt zitrone
man schmeckt voll vanille dann schmeckt
man wirklich so ganz leicht kirche und
nickel als ich mein ich habe die zutaten
da rein gemacht aber ich wollte dass sie
die probieren die blut doping ok seiten
bist du bist du bereit ich plane
dynatrace teile das auch noch ganz clean
neutral kam hierher nach vorne schießen
kliem du passt dass sie leute größter
fan
hast du schon probiert ob ihnen griffen
zu urteilen hat sie eine kreation der
fantastico geschaffen
[Musik]
ich möchte jetzt nicht sooo süß haben
attraktive erfrischend offen falls also
oh mein gott kalt ist hier noch geiler
hier habt ihr sie das ist die blue dog
so dass sam und kate macht sie auf jeden
fall nach es lohnt sich definitiv was
soll ich noch sagen
richtig heftig so lade aber damit
verabschiede ich mich jetzt auch ich
könnte jetzt noch stundenlang mit dieser
flasche ganz stolz stehen es ist einfach
total super wenn ihr noch mehr rezepte
hab dich ausprobieren soll dann schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare wir sehen
uns das nächste mal wieder biss dann
eure neue wanne
[Musik]